- Well, what university are
you going to sign up for?
What are you going to do?
And I was like, "Oh I'm
going to be an actor."
And she's like, "Well, okay,
but what's your backup?"
And I didn't really have one,
there was nothing else
I really wanted to do.
That's the first thing Ron said to me,
"You know, Thor's not going to fit into
a formula one car."
(audience laughs)
"I'll lose weight. I'll lose
weight. I'll lose weight."
You know, what usually scares you the most
is what doesn't actually exist, you know?
Even amongst doing it,
it's actually not so bad.
- Hello Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is Believe.
And I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So, to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
actor Chris Hemsworth
and my take on his Top
Ten Rules for Success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys liked the best.
Also as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
- Do you remember the first
actor who inspired you?
Someone you saw on screen?
- I remember watching
Brad Pitt a lot as a kid
and just loving sort of charisma
or whatever he was doing.
The type of films he was making.
And prior to even knowing
I wanted to be an actor
it was things like NeverEnding
Story and Princess Bride.
And those kind of films that I just loved.
- Do you remember the first time
you thought about moving over here?
- Yeah, it was when I was finishing school
and talking to you know,
the careers advisor at school about,
"Okay, well what
university are you going to
sign up for, what are you going to do?"
And I was like, "Oh I'm
going to be an actor."
And she's like, "Well, okay,
but what's your backup?"
And I didn't really have one.
There was nothing else
I really wanted to do.
And, and so, you know?
I put my head down and went for it.
Downey, very early on
when I got cast as Thor,
they brought me onto the set of Iron Man,
and I remember walking on, you know,
in just, track suit pants and a T-shirt
and seeing Downey there
in the Iron Man costume
and knowing that Avengers was coming up
and just thinking,
"How am I going to pull Thor off?
"And how the hell am I going
to stand opposite of this guy?
"And do this?" You know?
But he was, you know, he was great.
He gave me some great advice about
what an opportunity that
we were all involved in.
It wasn't directed you know, at me.
It was at himself, he was
talking the group, you know.
He knew Captain America
was coming, Thor, Iron Man
and he said, "You know, we're
part of something special.
"And this is, you know, going to be
"a hell of a lot of fun"
And, and that's it you
know, I think you got to ...
You got to enjoy the process, you know?
It's um, if you focus too much on sort of,
"What's the result of it all?"
You know, you're not
right in the middle of it
you know, this is going to sound cliche,
but in the moment of it all, you know?
And um, he kind of, that was
a nice kind of reminder of it.
And I tried to kind of keep
that with everything I do,
it's just ...
As an actor you don't control
the spectrum.
You know, that's the directors
and producers and stuff.
If you do theater, sure you
come out and do your thing but,
on film, on film you
do 10 different takes.
And you know, across how
ever many days you know,
60 days or whatever.
There's 40 or 50 different
versions of Thor.
You know, that Kenneth
Branagh caught together
in the first film.
You know, like, whether
you liked it or not that,
you know, that was a version
that was put together
by a lot of other people, you know?
And that was something kind of satisfy--
or it takes the weight off in thinking
"You know what, I can't control this.
"No matter how much I think I can.
"Or I try to."
Um, there's some comfort in
kind of, letting go with it.
And especially walking
onto a set like this,
with an ensemble like that,
it's like, "Good, we can
share this weight, you know."
Although the finger gets
pointed at individuals,
whether director, writer, actor, whatever
it's the same effort,
work or fail you know.
- Our first time meet,
I saw him trying to get
into a formula three car.
I cracked up, I thought,
"This is Thor trying to get into..."
- That's what Ron says.
The first thing Ron said to me,
"You know, Thor's not going
to fit in a formula 1 car."
(audience laughs)
"I'll lost weight, I'll lose
weight, I'll lose weight."
- Did they have to build a car for you?
- Uh, we had to pull the
seat out a couple of times
and I had to sit on the chassis
and the metal piping on the ...
but James, James was
the same height as me.
- Really?
- He was one of the
tallest Formula 1 drivers.
And had a hell of time,
getting in the car and um,
the weight I got down
to was similar to him
so I could, I understood his feelings.
- [Interviewer] The
biggest challenge in your
process of characterization.
- I'm sure there's, beside
me, what Daniel was saying
uh, as far as uh, you're
playing a real person.
And it's this iconic figure and
it becomes the, a whole
lot of responsibility
and weight and you
know, his family members
and what have you that
you want to be respectful
and you know, do it justice.
I've made the mistake of
going to a pre-kickoff party
for the film with a whole bunch of drivers
and people from the
industry who knew these guys
and I thought, "Oh this'll be great.
"You know, I'll get some good advice."
And, within like, five minutes
of being there I was like,
"What am I doing here?"
because everyone was like,
"Oh, you know he doesn't look like this."
And you know, "He speaks like this."
And, "What are you going
to do with the accent?"
And, "How are you going to walk?"
And it was like, "Oh my God,
these opinions." You know?
And um, but then I adopted the thing of,
you know what, just like he
approached life and driving
as did Niki, which was do it your way
and disregard the, you know,
sort of exterior opinions out there.
- [Interviewer] Thor
seems almost fearless.
Is there anything that scares you?
Like, in your life?
- In my life?
Look, a lot of things.
Mainly uh, I think most of us
our mind is sort of,
you know, convinces us things
are worse than they are.
Or better than they are,
it sets us up for a fall
constantly you know?
And this business, I think
about that a lot, you know?
About what's real, what's not
and what exactly am I doing
and what do I aspire to be and why,
and you know, all those sort of questions.
And I always come back to
just simplifying things.
You know, just sort of day by day.
You know, usually what scares you the most
is what doesn't actually exist.
Even amongst doing it,
it's actually not so bad.
You know, like that coming out here.
Before hand it was like, "Oh
my god, oh my god, oh my god."
But you get out here and you go, "Okay.
"I'm alive. I lived."
And um, yeah.
- Grew up near Melbourne, Australia,
in an aboriginal uh, community, huh?
- I did yeah, I grew up in Melbourne
and then moved to uh, Northern Territory,
in an aboriginal community.
There were buffalo and crocodiles
and it was a rather, you
know, unusual childhood
compared to the rest of the--
- Did your parents work,
move you there, or?
- Yeah, my parents worked
on a cattle station
with my aunt and uncle.
- [Kelly] I see.
- And so, we as kids, went up and just--
- [Regis] Well, that must
have been fun as a kid.
- It was great, yeah.
It was my introduction to life.
And it was vivid and as
exciting as it could have been.
- How does somebody start a career like,
like what you've accomplished,
in a community like that?
- Uh, you know, we were back and forth.
We didn't live there the whole time
but I think part of living there
you know, sparked some
you know, imagination.
And my dad read many books to us as kids
and always had a love for
story telling and films
and fantasy
and I think that was sort
of the beginning of it all.
And then it wasn't until I
finished school I thought,
"This looks like fun, I could
do this maybe as a career."
- So, you started acting in Australia?
- Yeah. I tried to.
I spent a few years on building sites
and horticultural laboring and you know?
It allowed me to take a
day off if I needed to.
- But then JJ Abrams saw
you as a part of Star Trek?
- Yeah.
- And brought you over?
- He did. Yeah.
I was in America at the time and just shot
a little independent film and came back
and it was JJ.
It was on a Friday night in his office
across his desk and he said,
and we read the scene, he said,
"That's great, you'll start on Monday."
And that was--
- Wow.
- The Starship Enterprise.
In Mark Ruffalo, you don't see the Hulk.
Which, is I think, the
perfect sort of contrast
because it's that sort of vulnerability
and that you know, um
fear of what's to come
if he does turn into that guy.
He doesn't necessarily like
who that guy is, you know.
But it's just a good bunch, you know.
I mean, Robert is uh,
is an actor and you know,
everything that he's done is incredible
and as is all of this cast
and so watching all of them work and
their different styles
and getting everyone
together in one big scene,
it's been really exciting.
- [Interviewer] Can you
tell me about working with
Kenneth Branagh, on this?
- Yeah, he's incredible.
Um, he was the first play I
ever did, or acting piece,
was "Much Ado About Nothing."
Which, you know, we all studied his film
over and over again.
So, to come full circle
and work with him now
is incredible.
Ken's one of the people
I've never been challenged
with changing things, you
know, doing it different.
Like, "Oh we got that, now try this."
And it really gets you
out of that sort of,
you know, bad habit of saying,
"Oh no, my character only does this."
And I think, when you limit
yourself like that you,
limit your possibilities.
Ken was all about experimenting
and just going for it
and taking that risk
and, it worked sometimes
and sometimes it doesn't
and you know, that's part of the journey.
- Hard to actually get the muscle bulk on?
- It was, the eating was
probably the most difficult part.
It was, it wasn't the fun
kind of eating either.
It was copious amounts of chicken breast
and various animal
proteins and what have you.
(men speaking over one another)
- [Female interviewer]
He reckons it's CGI.
- I wish it was that easy.
- Is that real?
- Yeah, I wouldn't have
spent 6 months in the gym.
It was, I read the comic books
and noticed the character
was 700 kilograms,
so that certainly lit a bit of fire.
- [Trainer] Again.
- I remember the first
time I read it, I thought,
"Okay. It's a, it's a horror film.
"You know, this is some different points
and the more I read
it, the more I spoke to
Drew, and Joss and once we were shooting,
and just saw what they
were doing with this thing,
it was like, "Wow, this is,
this is something special."
Both of them of such, kind of, um
you know, geniuses in their own sort of,
way about their knowledge of film
and you know, ideas for shots
and stories, and just that creativity
is just kind of like,
constantly sort of buzzing
and you know, every take
and you know, we're
two months in you know,
Drew after every take is like,
"This could possibly be
the greatest scene ever."
And you know, "I love this
film and I love my job."
And you know, so that enthusiasm
certainly uh is great.
Keeps the, keeps you
moving forward in film.
To do what we're doing
- Since you guys seem to be game today,
I would like to play a
little game with you.
- Okay.
- I love games.
- All right, I would like to have you guys
fill out the online dating
profiles for your characters.
- Oh.
- Uh huh.
- Oh, good.
- Okay, great.
- Okay, so first of all, you
need to choose a screen name.
- Uh ...
- WingNut.
- Honorable1.
- [Interviewer] Wow, that's sexy.
- WingNut was way cooler.
- Screen name?
Um, ThisIsTheRealMe.
- Oh! T-Hammer.
- T-Hammer! Sorry, it's T-Hammer.
- It's T-Hammer.
- [Interviewer] That's perfect.
- T-Hammer@gmail.
- It's all in the swing.
- HydingOutHere.
- Oh, like that.
- [Interviewer] Good one.
- Thanks.
- Occupation?
- Um.
- Hero.
- Well, hero, I mean, yeah.
- Provider of like, safety and good times.
- Nuclear physicist?
- All around nice guy.
Ugh, boring.
- Um, I'd be a linguist.
- Very good.
- Oh yes, you're right.
Okay, ideal first date?
- Color me mine.
- Oh, so nice.
- Yeah.
Roller-skating.
- [Interviewer] Hulk on roller-skates.
That could get interesting.
- You're probably like,
"Take them to the movies and a dinner."
- You're like, "I'll fly
them around the city."
- Myself, I'll probably fly
you to another universe.
- "Maybe we'll check out the nine realms.
"Aha I don't know."
You got any plans tomorrow night?
- Biggest turn on and biggest turn off?
- Biggest turn on?
- How about um,
honesty.
- Anger. Anger issues?
- For a turn on?
- Yeah. Turn on, yeah.
- Okay, right.
- Hey, big guy.
- Biggest turn off?
- You want me to answer the off?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Maybe tattoos.
- Dishonesty.
- Small shoes.
- [Interviewer] Men without anger issues.
- Mad men.
A man without anger issues.
- [Interviewer] Perfect, there you go.
- Is this for Tinder?
Is this where it is?
- [Interviewer] It could be.
We're goin to sell this interview to them.
- If you could step into the
shoes of one other Avenger
for a day, who would it be?
- I'd probably want to
play Captain America.
Just make him good.
- Just, just to play Thor for a second,
as an interesting guy.
As someone with layers.
- Wow.
- You know, layers?
You know, like, when there's
depth behind the eyes.
- I'd just make Cap a
little less predictable.
- Muscles are great,
but just kind of like,
Oh there's something beneath the veneer.
- What's Cap going to do?
The right thing, again.
- Maybe I'd love to bring Thor to life.
- That's so boring, isn't it?
- Maybe that's just me.
- Let me open the door for you.
No, that's sexist.
If you look into the meaning of that.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
George Sid asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in our future top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below.
And you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Imran Dean.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book:
"Your One Word."
And posting that great
picture to Instagram.
It looks so colorful.
I hope you enjoy that beautiful summer
or spring day when you posted it.
I really, really, really
appreciate your support again.
And I hope you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- [Narrator] Since entering
the Hollywood scene
in 2009's Star Trek,
Chris Hemsworth has
captured America's heart
tackling big roles like Thor,
smaller ones, like Formula
1 racer James Hunt in Rush,
- Never believed till now
my ratty, little friend.
- [Narrator] And even made
us laugh in movies like,
"Vacation"
- You could make hot water
come out of the cold faucet.
- [Narrator] and on SNL.
- Taxi!
Everything I do, you want it
to be different from the last
and um, doing thing like that just,
helps to reinvigorate you and
you learn different things.
Hello.
I'm here about the receptionist job.
- Hi.
- Abby.
We spoke on the phone.
- We did.
- Hello there. Okay.
- You're hired.
- Kevin is a big, dumb, puppy dog.
- It's a ken doll with
the insides scooped out.
- Kevin. Hi.
Can you answer the phone?
- Can't, it's in the fish tank.
- No, the one on the desk that's ringing.
That one.
- Oh! That one.
He has no idea what they even do.
What's this place called again?
- When I watch the movie I go,
"I just want more Kevin."
- Here's your coffee, Abby.
- Thank you.
Did you get sugar in it this time?
- I hate coffee.
Yeah, the sugar's in there.
- Sugar's in it?
- It's okay, not going to waste it.
- Chris Hemsworth is
a huge comedic talent.
- Seriously, there's no
way that you're this sweet,
this funny,
this fine,
it's just not fair!
- He's so funny.
He's such a funny improviser.
- Can I ask, why no glass?
- They just kept getting dirty, so,
I took 'em out.
- Kristen and I were fully crying.
We were laughing that hard
because of what Chris was throwing around.
- So, then it became a
character thing for him.
- Don't listen.
- I won't.
- He covered his eyes.
- Kevin thinks he's going
to become a ghostbuster too.
We need to form a group
and build something to
fight these damn ghosts.
- That's exactly what we already do here.
- Just takes a whole lot of the equipment,
gets a bike, builds his own uniform,
and is like, "Look! You know,
I'm one of the gang now."
- I asked Kevin to throw together
a couple of logos for us.
- Oh.
You can see how this
might make us look bad?
- Is it the boobs, you don't like?
Cuz I can make them bigger.
- Uhh.
- Do you know when the first
time you felt successful was?
Do you ever feel like,
"Yes, I've made it?"
- No, I think it's an
ongoing, you know, challenge.
There's things you feel proud of
and then there's films
where you feel like,
"Ah, I could've done
that better." You know?
Or, "I wish I had done
this or tried that."
I remember being in high
school the first time
I started thinking about
you know, talking about being an actor.
It was like, you know,
"I'm going to Hollywood."
That was sort of, you know, my thing.
And um,
it was just because I
loved those kind of films,
you know, as a kid, I loved that sort of,
films that took me to another place
or another universe and sort of
that vivid sort of concept
that took me out of reality
and transferred me to
you know, somewhere else.
And um,
and that was, even now,
I look at this film
and the first time I saw it was
when the visual effects weren't finished.
And seeing it last night
when they were finished,
and both times, you know,
I felt like a kid again.
I was entertained.
I was laughing, I was cheering.
All that, and I was in the film.
Honestly, when you're, from
an acting point of view,
it's really tough to
watch yourself, you know.
You're your biggest critic.
Anyone you know, not just as an actor.
A writer or anywhere in life,
we judge ourselves more than anyone.
You know, so when you get swept away
in the ride of it all then
someone's doing something right.
And I really felt that with this film.